des banderoles et des casseroles vides
levés en signe de protestation ce lundi
la population des dix plus grandes
favelas brésiliennes est descendue dans
les rues de sao paulo pour exprimer son
ras-le-bol face à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
l'aide d'urgence de 22 euros suffit
acheter une bouteille de gaz domestique
5 kg de riz et un kilo de haricots une
famille ne peut pas survivre un mot avec
cette aide
c'est une honte que le brésil un pays
riche avec tant d'opportunités l'est sa
population souffrir de la faim à peine
de quoi vivre quelques jours pour ses
nombreuses familles venues récupérer un
panier alimentaire 150 reais contre les
six ans ou moins de 90 euros qui avait
été attribué par le gouvernement l'an
dernier ed qui a été supprimés au mois
de décembre des décisions
gouvernementales
incomprise par la population fortement
impacté économiquement par la crise
sanitaire
il y a beaucoup de morts de chômage et
tout cela se passe à cause de la
pandémie dans le monde alors que le
président brésilien reste sur sa ligne
en prônant le retour à la vie normale et
la propagation du virus comme moyen
d'atteindre l'immunité collective
les gouverneurs tente de l'enrayer en
confinant localement mais le variant p1
rend impossible un quelconque retour à
la normale une situation qui contribua
femmes et les brésiliens les plus
nécessiteux surtout dans les favelas ce
cela me rend triste j'ai peur que mes
filles et fin l'une d'entre elles a
encore moins de 18 ans j'ai tellement
peur de ne pas avoir assez pour acheter
des choses pour la maison il ya aussi ma
petite fille et je me dis vont elles
avoir faim avec des bilans quotidiens
qui s'élèvent régulièrement à 3000 morts
le brésil est le pays le plus endeuillé
au monde par le coronavirus derrière les
etats-unis en nombre total de cas et de
décès les chiffres ont triplé depuis le
pic atteint entre juin et août 2020 mais
ne font toujours pas d'acier ball sonar
au qui a vu se succéder pas moins de
quatre ministres de la santé depuis le
début de la pandémie